in the lobby of Ramsey solution Samuel
and Brittany are with us hey guys how
are you good
welcome welcome where do y'all live
Raleigh North Carolina Oh fun welcome to
Nashville and here to do your debt-free
scream yes how much have you paid off we
have made about forty six thousand I
love it and how long did that take you
about thirty six months very good and
making what range of income during that
time we started off at fifty six nine
hundred and sixty thousand dollars and
we finished with an income of 72
thousand dollars with an in you start at
fifty-six thousand income and finished
with 32 thousand sorry 72 72 yeah okay
all right cool what do you all do for a
living I'm a teacher
uh-huh and I'm a sociopath stir of
children at youth oh very cool good for
you guys what kind of debt was the forty
six thousand student loans Oh Sallie Mae
yeah gave the old woman her eviction
notice for you guys very well done good
good for you what happened thirty six
months ago that caused this journey to
unfold so I started the process when I
was in college my mom was taking a class
and I started to take classes with her
and started that process for me so as
soon as I graduated college I stayed at
home for a year and paid off all of my
student loans and then we got engaged at
the end of that year and then over the
next year we started to knock off his
paid for our wedding got married and
continued to pay for his seminary loans
and paid for a car in between as well
and finally finished this past year very
good well so what happens is is that
finally both of you are out of school
and both of you are earning and that
really put it into overdrive right yeah
but in the meantime you're like weaving
in and out rying to get it trying to hit
it when you can and try to survive right
yes and we both took up lots of odd jobs
I'm I taught some lessons over the
summer to deter over the summer as much
as I could on summer break during the
winter when we get our ice and snow in
North Carolina he would get up at one
o'clock in the morning and go shovel and
well I grew up in Michigan so oh it's
nothing
it's not that yeah yeah yeah a bunch of
North Carolina people have no idea yeah
okay Wow
well very cool was that the worst odd
job you had no before that I well I was
working full-time with a landscape
company we did that on the side but
before that I was scrubbing toilets and
vacuuming hallways of a church and just
as a side job just to make ends meet and
did some of that but yeah my goodness
man y'all have done everything to make
it out yeah congratulations just got to
be extra special when you fight that
hard to claw that hard to get out yeah
the victory is special in that yeah yeah
I will admit though too
you know I was kind of when she was
talking about the you know getting out
of student loan debt you know I was like
well we need to do this and this and
this first you know people always have
student debt and it's it's just
something that you have until you pay
off later in life but she was a big
proponent of it and she you know saying
we need it we just need to get rid of it
now we need to do it and so I just like
all right well you're the CFO of our
family so why don't you just take care
of it and and the and short slowly but
surely I started you know becoming a
part of the process and good and and you
know it's been a great adventure ever
since so and we also have to think you
know my mother-in-law to who's been a
big proponent of that as well good very
cool yeah you don't have a chance you
were ganged up on there no well
congratulations you guys I'm very very
proud of you and I'm sure I'm sure your
mother-in-law is proud of you as well so
very cool and she with you guys today
she doesn't want to be on camera but
yeah here to support them that's awesome
it's good to have some cheerleaders in
your corner because when you're working
that hard and going crazy like that
there's always always a few detractors
that people to think you're crazy and
you have to have somebody to go no
you're not crazy you're just paying a
price to win and you're gonna win
because of its so no dis is the Bible
says no discipline seems Pleasant at the
time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness and that's where you guys
have been very very proud of it
congratulations you're heroes man well
done I'm gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's number one best-selling book
retire inspired and that
some next phase is to continue to build
wealth and and and continue to stretch
your generosity into the outrageous zone
the incredible generosity zone that's a
place to live and you know as a pastor
you're gonna it's gonna be easy for you
to do yeah and very very very cool well
congratulations you guys alright it's
Samuel I'm Brittany Raleigh North
Carolina forty six thousand dollars paid
off in 36 months making fifty six up to
now 72 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three to great job you guys
great job well done well done well done
that's how it happens right there hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income on a
$500,000 in economy
you